this is one of my absolute favorite
restaurants it's celebrating 25 years in
las vegas we're talking about lowry's
the prime rib vegas celebrating a
quarter century and have a special
lottery going on and to talk more about
that we are joined by michelle rizzo the
sales and marketing manager lowry's
thanks so much for being here today
thanks for having me i really do love
your restaurant it is absolutely
fantastic it is an experience it is and
i think that's one of the differences
that has sustained lowry's for so long
is you have a presentation that goes on
yeah it's dinner and a show the cart
comes to the table the salad spun at the
table you have everything right there so
you don't you can really skip the show
on the strip well maybe not but it is
it's definitely dinner show yeah the big
metal uh the big silver yeah and i
remember when lowry's first came like it
was announced that larry's is going to
come to vegas
everybody was like are they crazy it's
the town of prime rib and lowry's is
gonna and we have it's been 25 years oh
it's the it's
great
there are other places that serve prime
rib but not quite like larry exactly all
right so you guys are doing for
celebration you have a lottery going on
we are doing a scratch off it started um
this month we're doing it through the
end of the month if we still have
supplies we'll do it in june as well
okay so it'll be kind of while supplies
last
and you scratch it off and you can come
back um by the end of july to redeem the
the prize that you okay and i have a
card today you do and i get to scratch
it off live on there and the funny thing
is she said look if you win the grand
prize you can't keep it
because there's only one grand prize
what is the grand prize uh dinner parade
in your home so lowry's come to your
home if i get it i'm taking it okay i'll
i'll bring an attorney into this all
right i'm scratching off and what i get
is a free side of dessert
with a thirty dollar minimum purchase
all right that's fantastic coconut
banana cream pie i like it what are what
are some of the other sticky toffee
pudding i think i've had that one and
then our english trifle that's one of
the family recipes we've been doing that
for years yeah very just very popular it
i i just love the ambiance and there are
so many restaurants that maybe lack that
and this is not one of them this is a
place where it is truly an experience to
go out and enjoy an evening yes and
we're doing a freshen up this summer so
we're going to be freshening up the
restaurant and updating a lot of things
which we were supposed to do before
covet and then covet happens and then
everything shut down so we're finally
getting our turn beverly hills got
theirs in 2019. i love hearing that and
everybody that comes in will get one of
these scratch cards they could win the
grand prize what are some of the other
prizes real quick um 100 gift cards 10
off um
free cc brown sundaes salt and peppers
fantastic array of prizes all right
michelle thank you so much thanks good
to have you here mercedes over to you
all right